hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to potioncraft also known as
alchemist simulator only known by that
by me because i'm calling it that and
that's not the actual name of it and the
developers would be pretty offended if i
called it that but i'm going to call it
the name of my video that because that's
what it seems seem
[Music]
hi welcome to potion craft
have you ever wanted to be an alchemist
see i was right
i wasn't i wasn't lying you're a novice
alchemist wandering the world in search
of your destiny after a long journey you
finally found a place to ply your trade
you found an old abandoned house on the
edge of town judging by the alchemy
equipment and garden the former owner
seems to have practiced alchemy
apparently a wizard used to live here
but the layer of dust and condition of
the house suggests that it has been
empty for some time all right so we're
just going to accept that this is a
world of wizardry and magic and i'm an
alchemist
and that's dope as hell you decide to
turn the house into a potion shop after
several days of cleaning can i just grab
any house that i want
like is this squatter's rights
after several days of cleaning and
preparing the shop is ready for its
first customers it's time to remember
your alchemy skills and start this new
life in a new town with a new house that
i found and i definitely didn't murder
the previous inhabitants of it it's
weird the wizard seems to have not been
here for a while don't mind that it's
all nice and clean and all this fresh
alchemy equipment just happened to be
here
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
adding ingredients to the cauldron
potions are made from ingredients take
two terrerias and two water blooms
convenient i have two
uh plop
and oh that's satisfying
oh that's nice oh
that's nice i don't know where i'm going
after adding ingredients you can stir
the potions during the potion advances
the potion icon down the path defined by
the ingredients
i so whippy windy path
to the right to the right to the left to
the right and bam heating now the potion
icon is touching an unknown effect to
find out what the effect does you need
to add it to the current potion where's
the penile and biggening effect where's
the testicular enhancement where's the
brush
oh yeah i love this i love it already
perfect you've added the new effect to
the potion healing to finish baking the
potion press finish potion
all right
grinding ingredient a mortar and pestle
or an alchemist best friends you can use
the mortar and pestle to grind up
practically any ingredients and unlock
their potential now i know some of you
are confused because you hear mortar and
you think incoming
but it's not that kind of mortar i
thought
for a long time i thought it was mortar
and pedestal but that's because i'm an
idiot but mortar and pestle
i don't know what the origination of
those words are but i'm assuming it's
some kind of like medicinal thing the
more you grind an ingredient the longer
the path that ingredient will make on
the alchemy map once it's added to the
cauldron so can i grind it into oblivion
oh
[Music]
my god oh my oh
this is the greatest game
this is the greatest game this is the
greatest oh my god look at that
[Music]
okay
oh a different path completely grind the
water bloom using the mortar and pestle
this is the pest is this the mortar
i'm gonna guess who's the pestle because
penis and it looks penile
i slam my penal pestle into the water
bloom look at the way it stains the
pestle
look at the way look at the way look at
the way look at the way look at the way
it stains and the mortar i'm assuming
all right stir let's go down this road
wherever it's going to take us quicker
quicker quickly or quickly
potion
oh it took me to healing
weak potion of healing did this this
week oh
i can make a weak potion with less
ingredients by mortarizing them
that's dope as hell you saved the recipe
now finish making the potion i hope this
is just a game of exploration that
sounds pretty cool your task is not only
to brew potions but also to sell them to
customers a customer has arrived go to
the shop hey
how's it going people from all over town
and even other towns will stop in and
buy various magical potions your job is
to brew potions in the laboratory and
sell them to the customers many potions
must be brewed for a specific purpose
penis
many potions must be brewed for a
specific purpose but it's still a good
idea to keep a few of the most popular
options
potions on hand just in case if a
customer likes a potion it will be clear
from their reaction but they're not
going to tell me what they want
good afternoon yesterday at a friend's
party i burned my tongue on some hot
soup now i can't taste the thing and i'm
a brewer i need to be able to check the
quality of my product my tongue is
useless now
are you sure this is for
tasting
you don't need your tongue
you want that oh
can i haggle i'll haggle the hell out of
you okay
i'll buy this potion but i won't pay
very much well you're kind of a dick
then you and your stupid mustache go
lick a stone all right fine
hi lady my husband has been ill for some
time but recently he got even worse now
he can't even get up he has a fever and
sweats do you have any medicine for my
poor husband
let's see haggle
haggle
i'm gonna haggle haggle did i haggle did
i not haggle i thought that it was
supposed to go in the green and that was
haggling
all right whatever you will often not
have a ready-made potion for certain
customers that's okay you can always go
back to the laboratory to make the
potion they need there's no time limit
so you can focus on the recipe the
client will not leave not like you got
anything better to do do you yeah yeah
that's what i thought hello my sister
infested my hud even though i have a cat
the cat just lies on the cabinets and
watches the mice do whatever they want i
need a vial of rat poison so it'll be
easier to poison those rodents than wait
for the stupid cat's help
good call i'm gonna make poison go to
the garden where's my garden
garden chain garden is one of the
alchemist's main sources of ingredients
every day new ingredients will grow in
the garden don't forget to pick them
from time to time
[Music]
click
go to the laboratory
casper needs a poison which means you
need to create a potion with a poison
effect you will have to look for the
most of the effect on your own
throughout the map but you'll remember
your alchemy lessons that such a potion
can be made from one terraria and one
firebell
i just so happen to have exactly what
you desire
milady
uh don't mind that on the floors a
little bit
it's got some rad hairs in it for uh
poisoning
i seem to have reached a destination on
the map
let's take her for a spin
and blow
and shriek
[Music]
i'll save that
recipe nice
hey
how would you like a weak potion of
poisoning also known as poison let's
haggle come on
the arrows inside the golden bonus area
oh hitting the bonus areas tips to scale
in your favor but missing them does the
opposite scale will go gradually go up
i love you i i love you
uh the weather's nice books i love you
uh i love you
um
weather i love you uh
i'm i'm i'm winning you over with my
love and books
come on
i got this
and deal we're gonna get a deal we have
a deal ah
i got two more gold out of that for all
that work amount all the i love yous go
to the bedroom to end the day oh well i
guess i'm done i had a grand old time
i had a fantastic day
i can't wait to make such sexification
potions excellent you have refreshed
your alchemy knowledge and familiarize
yourself with the alchemy equipment in
the attic next to the bed you can found
ingredients and a ladle for water this
is your potion shop now and you decide
what to do next greet customers chat
hell potion is haggled and don't forget
to get the radiance ooh
i'm on my own
i'm free
freedom
hey
how's it going
healing potion bandit shot me through
the shoulder all right i can do that i
think i i think it was this thing
and then it was some of this what if i
put it all in the same blob
oh
seems like it didn't go in the same
blobbity blue
oh do i need water
oh yeah let's water it up
oh yeah oh you can go back to the center
of the map by putting water interesting
i put too much water in it
it's just a little bit of a grind just a
little bit
and then
all right that's nice i like that here
you go i'm gonna haggle the hell out of
you i love you beer sausages you like
sausage the ladies the ladies the lady
sausage weather
all right and deal all right that's
excellent what do you want invasive
beetles we need to poison them or our
harvest is doomed
i know exactly what you're looking for
you're looking for oops a shoot
well
that is not what i was hoping for
scooch
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
let's mix her up oh yeah
so you can go any which away you can go
every which away
excuse
uh lixian please add a nice sound effect
when the cauldron goes kaspoosh
i don't know why but i'm very suspicious
about what you're going to add and i
won't know until the video comes out
i'm sure it's fine
[Music]
all right
i trust you
have a potion you want potion i'll
haggle the hell out of you ladies books
books the ladies weather sausage you
look like a man who loves kielbasa and
the ladies
hi i have some strange soup lunch and
now i don't feel so good oof do you have
anything for a troubled gut well either
you want a healing potion or you want
something of like
constitution or stamina or something
like that let's go up let's kind of go
crazy with it let's see what's up you
know what i mean
let's go up let's see where this takes
us you know what i'm talking about oh
that don't look good oh that don't look
good at all
well
let's go right let's see uh where this
takes us
ooh a land of knowledge
i'm seeing a little bit of oh right
there that's the perfect mix
all right let's see if that gets us on
the the spot oh yes it does skoosh
what is this
ah mana that's not what i was talking
about well that sucked give give give
give give give give give all of this
um
let's see maybe you just want healing i
don't know
[Music]
splam
hey do you want healing oh all right
what about kilbasa what about kielbasa
weather ladies and books what about
books whether book lady kilbasa all
right fine
hello
are you new alchemist i'm the local
herbalist i gather plants and sell them
so want to see what i have for sale i
think i have something that might
interest you
so
[Music]
i only sell what i know about flowers
herbs roots and various bears and fruit
lemon okay show me your goods
what's this weird vine
whoa
that's a not so route okay but i already
have i'm gonna get some of these i'm
gonna haggle you
[Music]
done deal all right i will pay 55 and i
am
ashamed of it
i am ashamed or goodbye
i don't know what do i have here the
alchemist
oh
talent talent
talent strong and fast acting post
tonight appreciate you save your
questions kept our little steal a secret
your silence will be generously rewarded
of course
um
i know what you
need oh poison not po you said poison i
i was or whatever uh let's see
additional bonuses to give experience
when collected these bonuses
yeah
i know something about economies i know
what you want my friend i know what you
want i know what you want i am 100
on board
[Music]
i keep forgetting to mix her up
oh yeah you want big poison
you want honking poison
got it
all right my friend there you are let's
haggle i won't say a word about the
ladies books ladies weather book
kielbasa i know the magic words i know
that whoa
i oh my reputation um
oh
fire potion i'll coat my blade with it
and take that elemental down you got it
um
please say nothing about me
doing anything unsavory i need to
very gently oh yeah just like that
just like that just like that because
i'm gonna take a stroll
through red mush territory
oh yeah oh
oh yeah we're going off to the left
let's see where this takes us oh yeah
oh
ooh
okay
let's uh go up
wind bloom
oh god
come on come on
nailed it what's with the whirlwind
what is this
potion of light uh i need a fire potion
not a potion of light ooh are these like
portals that'll take me to somewhere
special like uh some kind of
otherworldly
[Music]
whatever have you
let's go on an adventure
let's see where this takes us
we're gonna go on an adventure i'm going
on an adventure oh there's something up
there
[Music]
what is this
ah potion of frost that was so close
that means maybe the other one's the
other way
you know what i mean i love this game i
love this
this away
yes yes
admittedly firebell would probably take
me towards
potion of flames and whatnot you know
what i mean you know what i'm talking
about oh yes it would
oh yes it do
oh it
definitely do
oh yeah oh i'm still there
oh
yes yes i knew that would happen i knew
it how am i gonna forget any of this
alchemy stuff like why would i even need
to save the recipe i already know what
they do hey it took me a while but man i
gotta hey i love you i love you um i
love you i love the weather i love books
i love books i love the weather i love
you i love book and haggle
done
what a coincidence command sent me to
fight an elemental 2 but this one is a
fire elemental
oh
i am already here baby the weather books
weather books weather whether the ladies
books kill bossa i know this it's like a
spell i put on them and they can't do
nothing about it they can't do nothing
about it all right basement do i have a
basement
oh i have a bit whoa
oh
oh my god
that's awful
all right well i think i helped kill a
dude but that's okay happens to the best
of us like people die it's not my fault
i only sold the poison
that does seem like it's my fault but
also shut up
it's not
all right i got that
look at the new ones
went fishing cast my line immediately
got a bite i don't know fish had some
teeth put me in here
okay fine i should just like stock up on
a few of these excuse me douche
healing potion it is healing person it
is
boring
there you go
book where the books and bam
[Music]
i was serving also i need to plow this
week oh
look what happened it started raining
today you want light
no that ain't it mana nah
okay you're going to burn them but
do you need a fire potion is that what
you're craving right now is that what
you're craving
is this what you want
still got it
skoosh
did you want fi oh fire i can't even
haggle visitors in a very bad mood and
won't haggle with you well screw you two
i love the weather and kilbasa but not
you
oh hello
it's nice to see new faces in these
parts i suppose you're the new alchemist
wonderful i'm the local mushroomer if
you're an alchemist then you must know
quality ingredients when you see them i
have a few mushrooms here will you take
a look
nope only mushrooms i have the best okay
well
oh that was a valuable mushroom
oh that was a valuable one
well that's a windy woo path
but they're cheap as hell so i'll take
some i mean if they're on sale i'm gonna
buy him but i'm gonna haggle the hell
out of yet ladies gilbasa kilbasa ladies
weather going doing going bam
i still paid a lot
all right
goodbye
goodbye hey says he has a great fear of
fire and refuses to use candles however
he still i have a potion of light
haggle haggle haggle
oh you are tough to haggle with
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh
yeah
hello carrie poison i'm the local
sorceress a witch if you like that's
what the locals call me anyway i didn't
come just out of curiosity do you happen
to carry poison why would a witch need
poison
sometimes our witch recipe calls for
poison and human blood but i'll get that
myself somehow
okay all right you know what uh you seem
like a reasonable witch you seem like a
very reasonable witch
i love haggling
i love it
there you go yeah no reputation change
okay that's fine all right now i get to
goddamn explore
oh yeah
now what's beyond the horizon
[Music]
what lies beyond
glorious knowledge
ooh we got a mystery potion
oh you can get like a rank two oh i
didn't even know that potion of bounce
ooh you can get oh i didn't even know if
that was the thing oh
interesting i don't think i have enough
to go up and left so i'm gonna wait till
tomorrow
all right i'm going to bed this game is
a goddamn delight
it's a goddamn delight you know it's
very rare that i come across a game
that's a goddamn delight it's got
experimentation who is this who is that
are these the wizards family is this the
wizards family is this the wizard's
dildo trunk what is in there
i don't like how i'm fingering it
um there's probably easter eggs all over
this place i bet i bet i bet i bet i
just bet i just bet hello ah a wizard
hello i see you recently opened i'm an
also an alchemist but i'm just passing
through town i'm collecting some
ingredients selling my alchemy equipment
so i decided to drop in i'm running
light right now and only have enchanted
paper sheets in the recipe book are made
of enchanted paper the chairman slows
down the paper's aging allows you to ask
existing recipes you can even completely
erase an old recipe and write a new one
instead in addition the sheets of paper
can be conveniently bounded to the real
okay i still don't know what the recipe
book does exactly i don't have enough
money i don't got enough money get out
of my shop no competition allowed i have
the brilliant ideas yesterday to brew a
beer that warms your bones even on the
coldest days people would pay a pretty
penny for it in the northern provinces i
need something like liquid fire oh do i
have that this is not perfection yet i
need one more
oh
[Music]
baby you're going to love this this is
literally going to cause someone to
spontaneously combust
i don't know what happens when i say a
recipe anyway this this is no
joke my dude what else do you add to
beer recipe for my beer is big seared
all i can say is i add five types of
fiery pepper to this one this is going
to kill someone
and i am all about that i have no moral
compass anyway how's the weather yeah
uh-huh
now that's a good price children who
wander into the forest to play by the
lake have started going missing of late
the villagers are certain it's a merman
i've heard merman flee at the sound of
thunder
under bounce you want to bounce you want
to bounce on the merman okay i have no
idea where the the sound of thunder
would
occur oh there's a potion down there
you'll probably cut through down that
way
let's do it
hmm is there anything that'll go kind of
like a cookie path no
all right i'm gonna be very cautious
there
the perfect mix
the perfect mix and then this
okay just
a little off
[Music]
i don't know what this does
lightning god damn it fast growth
interesting
not what i wanted boo
i love the nuance of it i love just
being able to
kind of do things i'm going to go in the
whirlpool i don't know what it means
it's probably bad probably resets here
or something i don't know but it seems
fun only one way to find out life is
about experimentation
what is this what have i done
there's something
over there
and what would this be pray tell
pray tell
what would this be
i don't know
let's find out hey
potion of lightning that's what this guy
wanted
potion of lightning you got that was a
tough potion yeah you better be willing
to pay for that it's top quality i
slaved over it for so long
so long you ever have a kielbasa
all right alchemist past chapter one
good job you completed the chapter with
each new chapter new visitors order
types potion bases merchants and
purchasable items appear continue to
complete the goals in the alchemist path
to unlock the full potential of your
alchemy equipment and learn all the
secrets of the trade this is a god damn
delight this game is lovely i love it
it's fascinating it's fun it's
so peaceful i love it i think this is a
fantastic game if you want to play for
yourself link is in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below
and let me know if there's a deep dark
secret to this game because it seems
like there might be
anyway
as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you